mais mais bonjour à tous alors je vous
présente le premier épisode de presque
adulte une mini série qu'on a écrites
avec cyprien julien josselin et flaubert
entre poteau d'une aide quoi je suis
content parce que tf1 et fanta qui
finance le projet ont complètement
accepté nos scénarios sans jamais rien
modifié du coup on a pu faire absolument
ce qu'on voulait de manière libre c'est
100% nous même si cette mini série est
aussi diffusée à la télé on n'est pas
racheté par la télé on ne se met pas à
faire de la télé ont pas commencé à
présenter la météo demain à tf1 je vous
rassure c'est juste un petit projet
artistique qui en plus d'être diffusée
sur youtube est aussi diffusée à la télé
une fois voilà c'est tout alors
attention
ceux qui s'attendent à voir une vidéo
youtube avec plein de blagues toutes les
3 secondes bonjour je suis un personnage
de podcasts et ben c'est pas du tout ça
un des vidéos comme ça on a plein sur ma
chaîne youtube et on aura encore plein
la presque adulte c'est autre chose
c'est une mini série on essaye de
raconter des histoires un peu plus sur
la longueur un peu plus sérieusement
mais pas trop non plus tant parce qu
adulte on parle du concept de d'être
adulte tien concept un petit peu
abstrait parce que qui peut réellement
prétendre être adulte en fait un
je vous le demande madame voit la ferme
ta gueule ce premier épisode que je vais
vous montrer là tout de suite dans
quelques secondes par le buffet
d'assumer ses parents ne pas les oublier
surtout quand on a commencé un petit peu
à vieillir d'ailleurs celui ci est
entièrement inspiré de mon vrai papa et
d'ailleurs je lui dédicace
alors ce premier épisode fait partie
d'une suite de 10 épisodes qui se
répondent les uns aux autres du coup je
vous recommande de tout regarder pour
vraiment bien apprécié le délire est
selon moi les meilleurs épisodes sont
les derniers donc je veux pas spoiler
mais je meurs à la fin aux
alors je n'arrête pas mes vidéos youtube
pour ne faire que presque adulte 1 je
continue mes vidéos youtube comme
d'habitude et presque adulte c'est un
petit projet parallèle supplémentaire
avec mes potes c'est toujours plaisir de
faire un petit peu de nouveautés surtout
pour l'été et pour ceux qui préfèrent
tout simplement mes vidéos youtube
habituel eh ben je vous rassure il y en
a plein qui vont arriver très bientôt
d'ailleurs soyez prêt parce que ça
arrive à la vitesse
de la lumière presque adulte est
diffusée tous les samedis soir à 20h45 à
la télé et pour ceux qui préfèrent
regarder sur youtube
enora 300 ma chaîne iii sur celle d'un
atout et quatre sur celle de cyprien il
ya clairement du favoritisme
merci d'avoir regardé cette introduction
j'espère qu'ils étaient pas trop chiante
mettez un petit ami je tape pour nous
soutenir et je vous laisse avec le
premier épisode
ciao
[Musique]
mais ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on
est pas venu ici tu vois cet arbre je le
connais depuis 29 ans j'ai retrouvé ta
maison à droite exactement la jarrie
dans cinq minutes
t'es sûr qu'il aurait un texto je crois
oui pointu points peut point passé déjà
mais toi tu sais pas si ces téléphones
hockey à tous
non vous pouvez pas vous restez ici je
vais tout seul qui est tranquille à la
dose de norman s'est pris son premier
atout dans cet arbre
[Musique]
être adulte c'est aussi ne pas oublier
ceux qui nous ont fait trop bien de
cette photo j'avais oublié julie et toi
première étoile
jenny clève pas ton monte oh non je sois
longtemps j'allais prendre mon carnet de
santé après je file j'ai le temps
j'espérais que pour une fois tu venais
simplement saluer ton vieux père
non mais je suis ainsi 30 dit un petit
peu quoi je fais d'une pierre deux coups
le carnet de santé puis ça toi wade
doucement dans deux ans la retraite
j'éteins servettien m mais tant mieux
j'ai envie de renouveau tu vois j'ai
envie de faire un petit potager dans le
jardin petites carottes petits pois
petits navets ou alors je vais carrément
m'installer au kenya d'accord on va
commencer déjà par le potager
j'ai encore on verra non et toi alors la
vie ça va ça se passe bien sur youtube
on revient bien vide greniers évasive
bien on y va on annonce mule que les
vieux démons et des parents qui
revendent les vieilles cartouches
pokémon de leurs gosses
un carnet de santé ou est-ce que je vais
je te donne si tu veux et un caban
d'argent frais que jamais à bentalha
c'est vrai que tu fais du monoski un peu
bizarre là s'appelle du snowboard
inquiet de souvenirs et quand j'étais
petit tu as tout garder c'est trop
mignon a annoncé c'est pas moi ça c'est
autre chose
ouais style à faire je les ai gardés à
bron jusqu'à ce que je les donne à guy
bon ok à la poubelle tu as raison je
passe à autre chose dans la vie autant
la page
merci pour ça et puis la prochaine c'est
dommage que tu reste pas plus longtemps
pour une fois tous les trois mois et
cela dure 5 minutes wen faut que j'aille
me qui m'attend dans la voiture bonjour
les enfants
bonjour je t'avoue ses copains on a
trouvé sans vie de grenier
c'est tout pas d'accord et moi j'y serai
du 45 tours bon j'ai bien pour les lire
mais les pochettes sinthian choix témoin
la gamegear dix balles me faut c'est
speed mukeba en face à une autre fois où
on y va nous mais je reconnais lui c'est
le petit cyprien celui qui peut laisser
craindre données ouais voilà c'est ça me
faut qu'on y arrive ce que j'arrêtais de
plus donc on va y aller il va et vous
entreprendre une non non pas plusieurs
minutes
pas de bennoo est la maman de norman
elle se réveille un beau matin disant
qu'elle a fait un rêve prémonitoire
elle me dit qu'elle a entendu des voix
qui lui disait qu'il fallait qu'elle
fasse un enfant là tout de suite
maintenant en moi si tu veux j'ai
entendu ça je me suis dit que l'on peut
tirer un petit coup c'est pas de refus
et alors on a commencé donc c'est bon on
a compris l'histoire a bien compris et
c'est comme ça que est tombée enceinte
de norman manley l'histoire c'est une
très belle histoire que j'aurais aimé ne
jamais connaître enfin le oui
regardez comme il est beau là avec sa
petite tête de vainqueur ah ouais sauf
que c'est pas moi ça c'est florent
bernard mois chaque côté ici à bout j'ai
toujours cru que j'étais toi et toi
quand est ce que tu nous ramènent une
belle blake
j'ai pas black on s'en fou n'importe
quel type de femme je vais copine donc
voila tu aimes pas les blacks n'étaient
pas racistes j'espère non mais j'étais
pas élevé comme ça
j'y pense j'ai quelque chose pour vous
bougez pas je reviens bon c'est vrai
j'ai totalement content de mon père est
en train de m'afficher d'hôpital arnaud
bantous qu elle est trop vite mais quand
même génial c'est parce que vous êtes
bourrés vous bon ça joue il est vraiment
cool on vrai j'avais que tu avais des 45
tours
rappel elles marchent encore après le
match mais jallet a bazardé je m'en sers
plus à temps papa phare des jeux étaient
tous les souvenirs de la vie comme ça
bêtement la poubelle c'est trop triste
c'est idiot de conserver les trucs là
c'est quoi
regarde là comme ça la prochaine fois
que je viens je ramène des vinyles et on
les écoute ensemble d'accords norman
et puis comme ça tu pourras médias
thaïlandais parce que moi je n'y arrive
plus tout seul
et puis à la cave à vide et aussi si tu
pouvais c'est la branche ehpad en régime
aoûtiens il ya plein de feuilles dans
les gouttières ça lui fait écouter un
peu de musique
1 c'est parti
ce matin même
aino
[Musique]
mt
et d'attaquer mais
mon père qu'on envoie un message pour me
remercier d'être passé effectivement
c'est bien mais on nous a envoyé un
message évident non je pense qu'il a
enfin trouvé la touche espace
[Musique]